the number one thing that I could tell
you is I think everybody lies for
themselves and I think all of you want
certain things to be happening with you
you want yourself to be something and I
think what you need to do more of you
know you have to audit who you actually
are who do your critics think you are
like what's the biggest criticism you
that you get over and over I I think
that people think I'm a motivational
speaker so what does that mean a book
artist yeah I think people think I'm a
boss and I you know what I understand
why America as a society has done a
really good job in selling us how to fix
the things that we naturally aren't if I
can bless everybody with one
characteristic I have it's not the
hustle it's not the stunning good looks
it's one thing it's self-awareness I
think the fear of using Trump's the
excitement of victory there's so many
people I know what I'm good at and I
know what I suck at and boy do I suck at
a ton of stuff but what okay pretty much
everything I suck at follow up like it
micro follow up like small details mean
nothing to me
you need to bet on your strengths and
don't give a [ __ ] about what you suck at
way too many people just remember gonna
spend the next 30 40 years of their
lives trying to check the boxes other
things that they're not as good at and
that you're gonna waste a fuckload of
time and lose
I don't spend any time on the things
that don't matter and what doesn't
matter is basically everything in
between the overall vision and strategy
and the real knowledge of it
there is no reason to do [ __ ] you hate
none promise me you won't because you
can lose just as much money being happy
as hell there is no loss and going for
him that yeah you might get made fun of
and you might have it in your own mind
but trying to figure out how to make
people laugh that theater nobody wants
the rejection nobody wants to lose so I
understand the philosophy I understand
that string of DNA that doesn't want to
make you lose the fact that I've been
working 19 hours a day every day for the
last 20 years is easy for me it's the
only here I knew right I was poor I
sucked [ __ ] at school it was the only
gear I had right so like I said here
with enormous disrespect and with
enormous assumptions around all of you
that you're just too soft to beat me
that alone doesn't allow you to beat me
I highly recommend auditing yourself or
if you have no [ __ ] empathy or EQ or
self-awareness then find somebody in
your family or friendship that does and
let them tell you who you are and once
you believe that either for yourself or
someone else told you go directly all
chips all into that because that is the
only possible way in my opinion watching
from the outside of over-indexing
because the truth is if you want to be
an anomaly you've got to act like one
executing the way it always is following
the school business model just such a
warship is gonna lead you to a place
where you're not going to win know the
details know the philosophy and don't
worry about all the my
the politics the process that all the
crap does not matter that's it I spent
all my time the clouds in the turf and
that's why I think I'm successful I am
NOT going to allow anybody in this world
not the media not my friends not my
detractors nobody define who I am I'm
going to find who I am for myself and
[ __ ] what anybody says about me or
thinks of me or things from doing
because I do trust my intuition one
could really a percent I know that I'm
built to win I always win I'm gonna win
execute against you it's so damn
important to stick to like your DNA
right and like what you're good at
nobody can define who you are guys I
mean you know the game has changed you
know we talk about all these products
don't be scared to be multi-dimensional
you're not unfocused you know nobody in
this world should define who you are you
could be so many things I'm worried that
people are confused that you know effort
or the secret or hustle is enough
because it's not it's part of the
equation
do you know how much of them in to in
the next six years
just for you that people don't have
patience I'm worried that people don't
tap into their strengths but talent and
skills and the ability to work hard and
having a thick skin do to help noxious
Li think my skin is when it comes to
business I don't give a [ __ ] there is
way too many people in this room right
now that are doing stuff they hate
please stop doing that if you want this
if you want bling bling if you want to
buy the Jets if you want to do
that's how you get who do your critics
think you are like what's the biggest
criticism you that you get over and over
um I I think that people think I'm a
motivational speaker so what does that
mean a book artist yeah I think people
think I'm a [ __ ] first and I you
know what I understand why I I on paper
meaning if you catch me in the right
environment if you catch me and if you
take certain if you clip certain parts
of this interview you can paint a very
both artist narrative I get it I think a
lot of people are cynical but I also
think that we live in a society where
there's been plenty of both artists and
I communicate like one I'm not confused
by that